good morning John VidCon is in a week
which as per tradition means that I am
experiencing a great deal of general
nonspecific anxiety usually for me my
anxiety comes from a place and I can say
okay there's a problem that I have to
solve them and hopefully it will solve
the problem that it will go away
VidCon it's not like that I'm just
anxious and then it's over and that I
just have to wait it out the only thing
I could do is distract myself which is
why I've written for vlogbrothers
scripts in the last week none of which
I'm using right now I did try to use
them but I felt dishonest talking about
anything except for the thing that I'm
actually freaking out about right now
which is specifically VidCon and because
I'm a professional / analyzer of things
whether VidCon and less specifically
online video and even less specifically
the internet is a good thing for
humanity and this isn't usually a
complicated question for me and that
leads to more connections between people
creating more cultural and creative
diversity and it increases everyone's
access dramatically to more information
and more free tools so it seems to me
that the Internet has had a very
positive effect on the world but there
are also things that I dislike about the
internet I dislike that the Internet's
focus on the very very cheap and the
free means that in order for platforms
to make money they have to consolidate a
huge amount of culture in one place and
have platforms that have hundreds of
millions of people on them and that this
in turn means that there's this massive
economy of scale which then means that
only a few people get very very rich and
they end up employing just regular
middle-class people not at all there are
also cultural effects but I'm ambivalent
about the recent user revolt that read
it over the site's interest in not
supporting hateful and actively abusive
communities confuses me and the Internet
is extremely effective at creating
pockets of bias and misinformation that
lead to the dehumanization of the
opposition but I think that the Internet
can also make people more tolerant of
other perspectives just by making the
existence of those other perspectives
more visible whatever the thing is that
we used to call Fame that I'm
uncomfortable calling Fame now has
started to seem really weird to me this
is probably because I now to some extent
actually experience the effects of this
thing what are that really great and
exciting things about online success has
always been to me that that success
comes along with the creation of a
community and a real relationship
between a creator
and the people consuming the content
they create but as this culture has
grown that relationship starts to feel
less real and maybe less important and
maybe like it doesn't even really exist
enough online success has started to
look a lot more like traditional thing
online culture is becoming mainstream
culture and I had to learn early on that
VidCon wasn't just gonna be affected by
that VidCon was gonna be part of that I
don't necessarily want online new media
to become mainstream media but it's a
thing that's happening this year at
VidCon Katie Couric is interviewing say
Frank
that's so yeah how are the blood
brothers we can actually sort of
actively D mainstream of Phi ourselves
by just making Lily like sort of more
off-the-cuff weird content that isn't
gonna be as popular but will still be
rewarding for the existing community but
then comes a lot bigger than us and that
means that VidCon is gonna change and
sometimes in ways that are gonna annoy
me very lucky and I take the
responsibility seriously that I can
steer the ship that is VidCon if I
really feel like I need to but there is
a current that that ship is in and I
can't and more importantly shouldn't
fight it because anything and I'm
extremely proud of VidCon and I'm
extremely proud of online video at these
last eight years of being involved in
this stuff has taught me anything it's
that you can't bottle up and control
culture you can and you should ask the
members of that culture to consider its
effect internet I think for the first
time in a long time gave a lot of people
about a normal people the feeling that
they could actually have a significant
impact on their culture they could
actually change things my hope is that
everybody leaves VidCon with that
understanding reinforced at these media
these platforms this entirely
unprecedented cultural phenomena is not
just something that you experience it's
something that we are all a part of John
I'll see you on Tuesday Oh God VidCon Oh
God